#HASHTAGWARS.
( APPLAUSE )
IF YOU'RE TRAVELING DOWN THE 5
FREEWAY AND WONDERING WHY
WHY TRAFFIC IS AT A STANDSTILL
ALL THE WAY FROM L.A. TO SAN
DIEGO WITH CARLOADS FULL OF
GROWN MEN DRESSED AS OBSCURE
JUSTICE LEAGUE OF MEMEBRS,
IT'S BECAUSE COMIC-CON STARTS
TONIGHT. TONIGHT'S PREVIEW NIGHT
AT COMINCON.
I'M MISSING IT BECAUSE I'M HERE.
YOU THINK I WANNA HANG HERE? I
COULD BE HANGING WITH TURTLE!
IN HONOR OF THE MOST WONDERFUL
TIME OF THE YEAR, TONIGHT'S
HASHTAG IS #COMICCONBANDS
EXAMPLES MIGHT BE:
DUNGEONS AND IMAGINE DRAGONS,
LANYARD SKYNYRD.
I'M PUTTING 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK AND GO.
>> YES, EMILY.
>> MILEY CYBORG.
>> YES, MILY CYBORG, WELL
DONE. JONAH.
>> WEEZER.
>> YEAH, POINTS.
JONAH RAY?
>> THE GRATEFUL WALKING DEAD.
NICE, POINTS.
KUMAIL.
>> DAREDEVIL IS BLIND MELON.
>> YES, WELL DONE! HE CAN SEE NO
RAIN.
JONAH RAY?
>> COLDPLAY WITH MYSELF.
>> POINTS.
JONAH.
>> INXL.
>> POINTS, EMILY.
>> MARCY COSPLAYGROUND.
OH, OK, YEAH, I LIKE THAT.
POINTS. KUMAIL.
>> COMMODORE 64.
>> NICE, THAT'S A PERFECT PLACE
TO END.